all right Bryce it is very good to see
you I there's so many things to dive
into so let's get right into it
um it's so funny because I obviously met
you right before your life started
moving really fast before you were the
number one overall pick now you're the
guy now you're in Carolina so with
things going so quickly like has it even
hit you yet that you're fully living out
your dream
um yes you know I mean it's definitely a
blessing to be
um where I'm at and with everything's
going on but you know at the same time
you know it's very conditional um you
know it's a it's a day-to-day type of
business so
um all my focus and concern has been on
trying to get better I'm trying to do
everything I can to help the team I'm
trying to embrace this process
um so because of that I don't think I've
been able to kind of rest on those
Laurels at all because again uh you know
the moment you get comfortable in the US
you know you're not push yourself you're
not getting better you're not getting
where you want to be um so uh you know
kind of yes or no but right now really a
lot of that focuses just been on trying
to progress yeah well what a perfect
answer
um but you know speaking of living out
your dreams you've been able to do some
really cool things we've all seen that
amazing Fanatics video where a lot of
you know Elite vet guys are talking to
the rookie is giving them messages your
player was Aaron Rodgers somebody that I
know you have grown up watching what all
did Aaron say to you in that video that
we maybe didn't see
yeah um you know I don't want to get
into the specifics of it um because
that's something I definitely
um you know I was really grateful for
and
um you know it meant a lot but you know
it was just really encouraging
um to be able to hear the words that he
had for me or to advice that he was able
to give
um where to support and you know like
you said someone that I've looked up to
for so long so I'm gonna have the most
respect for it to be able to hear that
um you know that kind of being a
welcoming gift to the league uh you know
really meant a lot um so I'm going to
continue I'm going to use the words of
advice that he said and continue to use
that and again it was a surreal
experience I'm super grateful for it so
what do you respect the most about Aaron
Rodgers game
um you know I really think it's the
command that he has on the field um you
could tell in All Phases of the game uh
he knows exactly where he wants to go to
the ball from the pre-snap to post-ap
operation um you could tell how much
ownership he takes in it
um and you know on top of that of course
the accuracy that he has the ability to
move the ball down the field to command
offense command the Huddle uh you know
Drive the ball when it's necessary
um you know the command on those two
minute drives on the game winning drives
those
um you know any game and they have
situations
um someone you can tell takes a lot of
pride in that um but I think really just
him being a true a true Field General
um someone who you could tell is in
control
um that people buy into and you know
that's evident just from Washington
um so you know I think those are just
some of the things that you know I've
been able to watch and Admire from afar
for so long um and you know I'm gonna
continue to watch him and learn from
I love that okay let's talk about a few
more Legends before we get to you
um Michael Rubin also had Tom Brady talk
to you and some of the other top
quarterbacks in the draft class I know
that he gave a message but you all are
also able to ask him questions so what
did you ask Tom Brady and what advice
did he give you
yeah um again I don't want to get too
exact on on what he said it was um you
know it's stuff that I definitely
um you know that I I hold hold dearly
and will remember so um you know I
without being too specific it was a lot
about
um kind of his experiences throughout
the league um his experiences as a Young
quarterback and what he was focusing on
and what he was working on and
um you know things that he really Pride
himself on early on in his career and
you know you know really one of the
things that I asked that you know people
um that we had talked about her
discussion about was you know trying to
you know see things that he wish he knew
um you know when he was um in our
position young rookie quarterback coming
into the league and you know he was
super insightful you know it was great
for him to be able to give that time and
you know it was super humbling
experience to be able to talk to him and
have those discussions and
um he gave some great answers you know a
lot of advice that again I'm gonna uh
you know I'm always gonna remember and
you know hold dear to how I I carry
myself and you know how I work in this
this profession but um you know it was a
lot of insightful things that he said
um and you know those were just kind of
a few of the things that you know we all
wondered that he he spoke on but there
was a lot more gems in there as well
yeah I'm sure I'm sure I hear it was a
very fruitful uh lunch I'm very happy
that you got to be a part of it um let's
talk about you some though I'm sure it
has been incredibly tiresome for people
to consistently bring up your size so
when people bring up your size what do
you want them to talk about
um you know to be honest with you I'm
cool with whatever opinion comes with it
um you know honestly I think that's the
beauty of sports you know uh we all get
to come together and talk and have
opinions and um you know whether it's
negative or positive I'm kind of good
with it um you know I know myself
um you know there's only one way I know
how to play this game and it's you know
at this size relative to the people
around me
um so yeah of course it's something that
especially throughout the pre-draft
process was talked about a bunch and I
heard all the time
um but again it comes with a territory
um you know I I get it I'm not the
traditional size
um of most quarterbacks in the league I
you know I'm well aware of that but
again I focus on what I can't control
um you know I know myself I focus on you
know now I'm getting better day in and
day out and doing everything I can to
tell the Panthers so you know honestly
whether it's good bad or indifferent
um whatever people want to talk about
size-wise I'm I'm good with it I feel
like Everyone's entitled to their own
opinion and
um you know for me I'm just focused on
what I can't control I'm sure that is
the attitude that you have to have a
word that comes up a lot though when
people are talking about you is your
Poise where did you learn Poise from
um you know I think it was it came from
a lot of different facets of life not
just Sports um you know I'm I'm grateful
to have the the parents that I do at the
sports just and I are doing and my
parents you know that's something that
they've always instilled in me and you
know really where it comes from is is my
faith um I believe that you know
everything's written I believe that you
know I'm gonna do everything I can to
try to put myself in the position of
what I think is best and try to do
everything I can out the team but you
know at the end of the day I feel like
you know God's author to my life he's
gonna put me in the positions that he
wants me to be you know and whether
that's something that I understand the
moment or you know I don't get till
later I never get um you know I I still
trust in him and what's gonna happen and
because of that I do everything I can to
trust in my my preparation trust the
work I put in
um and you know put my best foot forward
and then ultimately I think when you do
that you know God's gonna be the one who
controls your outcome
okay well talking about all these
Legends all these goats made me want to
play a game okay
we are going to build the perfect QB
using different characteristics that you
can put together so what characteristic
would you like to take from Bryce young
and then you can build it out from there
they can be past quarterbacks or current
it doesn't matter
you know it's crazy this was actually a
combine question for me I got this oh
God it's in the combine so it was it I
didn't have as big of like a pool of
people to choose from though so I'm
gonna try to I'm Gonna Keep It original
okay
um from myself
um I'd like to say my consistency in my
Approach um that's something I pride
myself in
um so you know I think I I guess I have
to take that since
um again it's something I pride myself
in and not just you know football and on
the field stuff and off the field stuff
just trying to be consistent
um you know that's something that I I
believe in a lot so
um consistency
um you know I I guess if we're starting
with me I'll go with myself all that
um what was the next category you can
pick whatever you could do arm strength
you could do yeah whatever
okay speed whatever
speed like I'll go overall like agility
speed I guess I got go Lamar for sure
okay uh but Dick's in there too this is
this isn't a tough this is not it is
tough that's why it's a game gosh I
don't know if I could choose between Vic
and Lamar I have too much respect so
we'll let you put both first Speed and
Agility okay for that option
um what about pocket presents
pocket presents um
I go I go
I'll go Brady for pocket presents
um honestly whatever you know it was a
lot of categories that Brady could have
went in so yeah um but that's that's the
first opportunity so I'll take it I'll
go you know I'll go for as far as just
um you know I'll go Aaron Rodgers for
um his ability to make throws in
different platforms that's something
that I've definitely um that I've
definitely learned a lot from
um you know he's been able to do so much
different things with his lower body and
be in different places and
um you know be in different timings but
still be able to be consistent and throw
emotion she'll be able to deliver the
ball accurately
um and get through his progression it's
something that I Model A lot um Pat
Mahomes creativity oh good one I think
just his creativity he's changed the
sport um he's been able to you know just
change how things are packaged how
things look what's acceptable to do as a
quarterback um he's been able to be
efficient in ways that were very
non-traditional before
um so I'll go with I'll go with that
um am I missing anything no I think you
got all of them but I'm gonna add my own
category who would you want for just
like their swag you like what they
represent as a QB who's who's your swag
pick
it's a tough one I'll go between
I'll go between Jay Hurst and uh Joe
burrow between those two I like that you
can tell guys that are in command
um play with the swag team that's I
think I wouldn't say understated but
they don't have to do to like you can
just tell you can watch them play you
see the command it's not some active
facade they're not doing too it's just
you could tell us who they are so um
I'll go with them I love it yeah they're
just they're just cool okay I'm into it
uh two more questions for you
um obviously so much hype surrounding
you and what you're going to do next
year a lot of expectations are on you
but people expecting things from you
means that they see the talent that you
have so of all the expectations that you
feel are on you which one means the most
um you know for me I think the only
expectations that I'm focused on are the
ones that we set as a team and that I
have myself
um and you know once I have for myself
are aligned with with the team
expectations and and team goals um you
know like you said it comes with the
territory of people have any
expectations and opinions and wanting
things to to look a certain way and
again I feel like Everyone's entitled to
that
um but for me I really put my energy in
what we establish as an expectation as a
team
um and that comes from within the locker
room within the quarterback room within
the meeting room um and just here within
the building
um we have expectations for ourselves
and that's what we hold ourselves to
um every day that's what you know I try
to pattern myself
um after every day at you know whenever
I come into the facility
um making sure I hold myself to those
expectations and those standards so
um you know I think for me those are the
ones that are most important okay
amazing and through this kind of
Whirlwind of things that have been
happening you've been able to be in
rooms with a lot of accomplished people
a lot of really cool people is there any
conversation that you've had
um maybe at Michael rubins that has
really uh stuck out to you
um I mean it's definitely the the
conversation with with Brady um I think
with us to be able to have the time that
we had
um and you know also with obviously like
you said with with uh Michael Ruble
being there Travis Scott being there
there was a lot of wisdom within the
room and it was a dedicated time for us
to sit down and ask questions and have
dialogue be able to talk about things
and I'm grateful for the times I've been
able to you know pick people's brains on
the Fly and get a question here there
um without trying to make it like an
interview or something
um but for there being a a real time
where that was what was dedicated
um you know what we're supposed to be
talking about you know they're being
tent behind it and you know it helped us
you know on the receiving end and them
to be able to have a message for us and
to you know there not just be me trying
to get something and decipher it but
them actually trying to help us and give
us wisdom in the different facets of of
life that they all have so much success
in
um you know that that definitely was was
what would stand out the most amazing
okay well as an interviewer I just have
to ask this because now I'm curious you
talked about somebody asked you with the
combine the question I asked you what
was your favorite NFL combine question
um that was it I gotta find a second one
though that that one was like uh uh it
was of all the quarterbacks in the in
the draft what you know make like a
Frankenstein quarterback oh I like that
it was like specific like and they went
it was like they went by like body part
like they went from the ground up like
legs like Mobility like arm like all
this stuff like different like so that
was that was that was the one that stood
out the most I'd say second to that
um what else was a good one there was
some like there was some stuff about
like I want to say it's like a middle
school question that it wasn't like a
crazy question but it was just more like
wow we're talking about like eighth
grade
what happened to me when I was 10 years
old yeah I was like wow like I don't I
don't know how you even found that out
but I mean it was like it was it was a
football related about like team I was
on eighth grade and I was like yeah like
I guess you guys did your research like
I mean where's the answer but I I
appreciate you guys for for spending the
time well that that eighth grade team
were y'all good
they said I need to know if you saw this
early no I uh I appreciate your time I
cannot wait to watch you this season of
course rooting for you can't wait to see
all the things that you do and I'm happy
that up to this point everything has
gone exactly how you have planned so I
appreciate it
thank you I appreciate your time as well
foreign
[Music]